[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم واهلا بكم قالت مصادر عسكريه
امريكيه ان ضربات التحالف في سوريا
ستتواصل وان وتيرتها ستعتمد على طبيعه
الاهداف وقالت القياده المركزيه الامريكيه
ان الضربات ضد ظ الدوله وهي الاولى من
نوعها انطلقت من سفن حربيه في المياه
الدوليه في البحر الاحمر وشمال الخليج
وانها دول عربيه تشارك في الهجمات الشجريه
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما هي الاستراتيجيه التي سيعتمدها
التحالف الدولي في حربه ضد تنظيم
الدوله وما هو معيار الانتصار على تنظيم
الدوله بدون حرب
بريه
اذا فقد بدا تحالف دولي تقوده الولايات
المتحده ضرباته ضد مسلحي تنظيم الدوله اول
الصواريخ انطلقت من سفن حربيه في المياه
الدوليه في البحر الاحمر وشمال الخليج
وبمشاركه دول عربيه خبراء عسكريون يشككون
في قدره الغارات الجويه والهجمات
الصاروخيه بالقضاء على تنظيم الدوله ودحره
ويؤكدون ان لا سبيل لذلك الاقحام قوات
بريه وهو ما قالت واشنطن انها لا تنوي
فعله التقرير للزميل ناصر ايت
الطاهر التحالف الدولي لا يضيع وقته من
الجو اطلق هجماته بسرعه تضاهي السرعه التي
انبثق بها تنظيم الدوله ونمى وانتشر لكن
هل بهذا اليسر يدحر التنظيم الذي سيطر على
مساحات من الاراضي في العراق وسوريا واعلن
الخلافه في قلب الشرق الاوسط وهل العمليات
الجراحيه فعلا وهي من الدقه بحيث تضرب
معاقل التنظيم حصرا الاكيد انه لا مؤشرات
بعد على ان تنظيم الدوله قد ناله ضعف
فالمشهد على الارض مختلف فرع التنظيم في
العراق مثلا سيطر لتوه على مقر الفوج
الثالث بعد محاصرته عده ايام وقتل من
الجنود العراقيين المئات كما اسر العشرات
واذا كان ثمه من استراتيجيه للتحرك الدولي
ضد التنظيم فهي في الغالب قد اعدت على عجل
يقول خبراء عسكريون فهم يشككون في قدره
الغارات الجويه وحدها على القضاء على ما
وصفه مسؤول امريكي بانه جيش من المتمردين
المطلوب اذا نشر قوات قتاليه وذاك توجه لا
تتحمس له الاطراف المنخرط فيما يسميها
الرئيس الامريكي معركه كل الدول الرافضه
للارهاب في الشرق الاوسط حتى واشنطن التي
انتقل خطابها بعد ذبح صحفييها من احتواء
التنظيم الى تد
كانت منذ البدء واضحه لا جنود امريكيين
على الارض موقف يحركه ربما اعتقاد بان
قوات محليه يمكن ان تطلع بمهمه السيطره
على مواقع تنظيم الدوله فعن اي قوات نتحدث
في سوريا لا رهان ممكنا على جيش النظام
بعد اذ اقصي مثل حليفته ايران من التحالف
الدولي الفتي ولا تبدو المعارضه المسلحه
هناك بديلا ممكنا بسبب قله تسليحها وت
مقارباتها للتحالف
نفسه اما العراق فتعرض حكومته الجديده اي
مشاركه لقوات ميدانيه اجنبيه في محاربه
تنظيم الدوله على اراضيها لكن جيشها
مدعوما بقوات الحشد الشعبي دون مستوى تلك
المهمه وهو الذي يتكبد لا يزال خسائر في
هجمات ومعارك مع التنظيم اما المراهنون
على قوات البش مر الكرديه فلم يسمعوا موقف
قاده الاكراد القاضي بعد القتال خارج
اراضيهم من اذا بوسعه حسم المعركه مع
تنظيم الدوله اذا كانت ثمه رغبه في ذلك
وهل يكفي الحسم العسكري اذا تم دون تفكيك
التنظيم ايديولوجيا ودون حل ازمات
المنطقه موضوع حلقتنا هذه نناقش مع ضيوفنا
من واشنطن الجنرال مارك ميمت مساعد وزير
الدفاع الامريكيه الاسبق ومن بيروت العميد
المتقاعد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي وعبر هاتف من جده الكاتب
والمحلل الاستراتيجي الدكتور علي بن حسن
التواتي نبدا معك جنرال مارك كيمت ونود ان
نعرف السؤال الذي يطرح على نطاق واسع
الليله بعد ان بدات فعليا هذه الضربات
الجويه للتحالف الدولي ما الاستراتيجيه
المعتمده في هذه الحرب على تنظيم
الدوله اعتقد ان علينا ننظر الى شيئ شيئين
اولهما المدى القصير والاستراتيجيه بعيده
المدى قصيره المدى اشار اليها الجنرال
ميفل من قياده القوات المشتركه اذ قال
انهم يريدون التحقيق انهم حققوا شيئين في
ضربات الليله امس
اولها تعطيل
قدرات تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه من قدرات
سيطره ونوعيه
وتشكيلات
وثانيا الهدف الثاني هو هو استهداف
المجموعات او مجموعه ارهابيه قالت
مخابراتنا بانها تستعد لتوجيه ضربه اما في
اوروبا او في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اما الهدف بعيد المدى فهو يبقى الحاق
الهزيمه
وتدمير تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه كتنظيم
ارهابي في المنطقه وهو امر حققت له
الولايات المتحده التحالف ضمه على على
الاقل 40 دوله منظمه لمعركه ينظر اليها
بشكل عام انها تهديد للعراق وتهديد
للمنطقه وفي الواقع للعالم برمته هذه هي
الاستراتيجيه انت الى حد الان لم تحدثني
عن الاستراتيجيه الجنرال مارك كيمت لكن
حدثني عن الاهداف التي وضعت منها ما حقق
على المدى القصير الليله الماضيه ومنها ما
هو على المدى البعيد ما قصدته
بالاستراتيجيه هل من خطط واضحه المعالم
وضعت فعليا من الالف الى الياء في هذه
الحرب على تنظيم الدوله خاصه وان هناك من
يشير بانها لا توجد او حتى ان وجدت فانها
وضعت على
عجل مما لا شك فيه ان الخطط لم توضع بشكل
مستعجل ولا الاستراتيجيات حسب تعريفك
الاستراتيجيه ف ان رئيس الولايات المتحده
قد عبر عن ما يرى انه استراتيجيه شامله
تماما تشمل كل عناصر القوى الدوليه وغير
الدوليه فمن جانب العسكري فهو استخدام
القوه العسكريه لتدمير تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه على المدى البعيد ومن ناحيه
اخرى جمع عدد من الدول الجيده التي تدرك
جميعا بان داعش تمثل ليس خطرا عن العراق
فحت على العالم كله وا ايض استخدام القوه
العسكريه
والعمليات التي تقف امام ايديولوجيات داعش
وايضا ايقاف التمويل هذه هذا التنظيم الذي
لديه موارد ماليه لا حدود لها و ايضا
القيام بعمليات ضد الحدود لمنع تدفق
المقاتلين الاجانب من والى مناطق النزاع
هذه عناصر الاستراتيجيه كلها ستؤدي الى
النتيجه المتوقعه والتي وضحها المجتمع
الدولي الا وهي الحاق الهزيمه وتدمير
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
ومقاتليه اتحول الان الى بيروت والعميد
المتقاعد الياس حنا السيد العميد الياس
حنا يعني سرد الجنرال مارك كيمت بشكل مفصل
عناصر هذه الاستراتيجيه لكن الجميع يعلم
بان الولايات المتحده كانت واضحه منذ
البدايه بانه لا قوات بريه سترسلها ولا
جنود امريكيين سيشاركون على الارض بهذه
العناصر الى اي مدى باعتقادك استراتيجيه
كهذه مكتوب لها النجاح
في ربما القضاء على هذا
التنظيم اولا الحل ليس عسكري بحت وهذا ما
يؤكد عدم عسكر امريكا على الارض او حتى
عسكر من خارج العراق ومن خارج سوريا فاذا
نحن نتحدث اليوم عن حل عسكري محدود اي ضرب
ضرب القدرات منع الانتشار الاقصى لان
التنظيم وصل الى الامتداد الاقصى الهدف
منه هو اضعاف هذا النظام وخلق الاليه
السياسيه ان كان على الساحه العراقيه او
على الساحه السوريه من هنا بنظره
استراتيجيه كما تحدثتي يبدو ان الامريكيين
لديهم مقاربه معينه اولا فصل المسرحين عن
بعضهما البعض وهنا تبدا الضربات لتاخذ هذا
المعنى لانه وصل المسرح العراقي او المس
المرح العسكري او السياسي العراقي مع
المسرح السوري هذا امر يريح التنظيم فاذا
اليوم انطلقت الضربات العسكريه الى العمق
الاستراتيجي الى ستراتيجيك دبث ل تنظيم
القاعده الرقه والتي تعتبر العاصمه
المفترضه للخلافه وهي مركز الثقل ومن
نوعيه الاهداف يبدو ان المرحله القادمه هي
العزل بين المسرحين والانطلاق الى العمليه
السياسيه العمليه السياسيه في العراق يبدو
انها قد تاخذ المج ج مع صعوبات كثيره ولكن
المشكله الكبرى التي سيواجهها الامريكيون
هو المسرح السياسي او العمليه السياسيه
ضمن سوريا ومن قال سيدتي انه يمكن تحقيق
النصر او قياس النصر على هكذا مجموعات في
حرب لا تمسليه السمتر ومن قال ان الولايات
المتحده فعلا تريد الانهاء التام لهذا
الواقع انا اعتقد اليه سياسيه شبه دوله في
العراق شبه دوله في سوريا وهذا هو معنى
جاح بالنسبه للولايات المتحده سناتي ونفصل
كثيرا بخصوص هذا النجاح الذي ترنو اليه
الولايات المتحده مدعومه بكل الدول في
حلفها نتحول الان الى جده الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي الدكتور علي بن حسن التواتي دكتور
علي يعني دول الدول العربيه المشاركه في
هذا الحلف الذي تقوده الولايات المتحده في
محاربه تنظيم الدوله الى اي مدى تبدو هذه
الاستراتيجيه جيه واضحه اليها الى اي مدى
تم اشراكها اصلا في هذه الاستراتيجيه وهي
على علم بما
يدور يبدو للاسف اننا قد فقدنا الاتصال
بالدكتور علي سنعود اليه حتما خلال هذه
الحلقه اتحول مره اخرى لجنرال مارك كيمت
جنرال الجنرال الياس حنا اشار الى نقطه
مهمه وهي انه ربما عدم وجود قوات بريه
داخل الاراضي اراضي هذا هذه الحرب التي لا
تبدو يعني واضحه المعالم الى اي مدى
باعتقادك يمكن فعليا ان ان ان يضعف من
حضوض نجاح هذه الحرب التي تحدث عنها
اوباما بانه بانها تهدف في البدايه الى
اضعاف التنظيم وممن ثم انتقل الى ضروره
القضاء على هذا
التنظيم هناك شيءان و قولهما اولا من
الواضح ان الضربات الجويه سيكون لها تاثير
كبير على
قدرات تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه في العمل
بعد تط العمل في مجال ضيق جدا وثانيا اقبل
رايكم بانه دون قوات ارضيه
بريه البناء على النجاحات تحقق الضربات
الجويه لا يمكن تحقيق الهدف النهائي لذلك
فان الولايات المتحده كجزء من
استراتيجيتها وضعت خطه او
عمليه لتسليح وتدريب
المعارضه او القوى السوريه المعتدله الذين
لا يقاتلون قوات الاسد فقط بل يقاتلون
القاعده ايضا هذا التدريب وهذا التجهيز
بالمعدات والاسلحه سوف يجري في اماكن مثل
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بحيث انه يمكن
تطوير وتدريب قوه منظمه منضبطه من الثوار
السوريين لالحاق ليس فقط الهزيمه على
الداعش على الارض بل ايضا ليستطيعوا في
مرحله ثانيه من هذه العمليه ال الاطاحه
بنظام بشار الاسد داخل سوريا اعود مره
اخرى للدكتور علي وسنعود حتما للنقاش مع
الجنرال مارك كيمت والجنرال الياس حنا
دكتور علي كنت اسال قبل ان يفصل الخط معك
عن هذه
الاستراتيجيه التي يخوضها التحالف في حربه
ضد تنظيم الدوله هل تبدو لكم مقنعه الى اي
مدى تبدو واضحه المعالم بالنسبه اليكم
خاصه مع حديث الولايات المتحده عن غياب اي
قوات بريه على الارض الا القوات العراقيه
الجيش العراقي والبشمركة
المتعدده ربما ولكن مسرع عمليات واحد وهذا
فرضته داعش بنفسها ان جعلت دولتها او جعلت
تنظيمها ينتشر في دولتين بحيث انه لابد من
ضربه في كافه المناطق سواء في سوريا او في
العراق بشكل متزامن ولا يترك له فرصه
لاعاده التجمع في منطقه دون اخرى فليجب ان
يكون الضرب متزامنا في الميادين المختلفه
ايضا لا يمكن لحرب جويه ان تستمر الى ما
لا نهايه لانه هناك عوامل تدخل اخرى من
يقول ان بشار الاسد وقواته لن يستغل هذه
الاوضاع مع دعم من حزب الله ودعم ايراني
بري ويستفيد من هذه الهجمات بفرض نفوذ
خاصه على المناطق الشماليه في حمص وحلب
وادلب من يقول
انه انه الكل يبقى محايدا
وينتظر القصف الجوي ليستمر عده اسابيع او
اشهر او سنوات هنا لابد ان نكون اكثر
وضوحا اذا كانت لا توجد قوات بريه جاهزه
للتدخل فلا بد من الاعتماد على قوات
التدخل السريع على قوات الصاعقه القوات
المنقوله جوا اي قوات الى الى اي دول
تنتمي والعراق كان واضحا ايضا مثل ما كانت
الولايات المتحده واضحه لانه لن يقبل اي
تدخل اجنبي على اراضي اذا اذا في هذه
الحاله نحن نتكلم عن عمليات تدمير اليوم
ما اعلن انه قتل على الاقل كمان مدنيين
عمليات تدمير بدون بدون وضوح اهداف هذا
ليس دوله هذا
تنظيم خفيف الحركه ينتقل من مكان الى مكان
يختبئ بجبل يختبئ بكهف يختبئ فحينما نتكلم
عن
قيادات وسيطره و يعني نحن نبالغ قليلا وضح
وضح تماما نقاط عديده اشرت اليها مهمه
سنعود حتما اليها لكن الان مشاهدينا
الكرام سننتقل الى فاصل قصير نناقش بعد
هذه الاستراتيجيه استراتيجيه التحالف
الدولي في الحرب على تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه ابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش استراتيجيه التحالف الدولي في الحرب
على تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه نعود مره اخرى
الى ضيوفنا الكرام العميد المتقاعد الياس
حنا يعني ضيفنا الدكتور علي اشار الى
العديد من النقاط نواد ان نقف عندها تحدث
عن ان هذا التنظيم هو تنظيم متحرك طبيعه
ربما المعركه مختلفه تنظيم خفيف متحرك
وبالتالي انه ربما هذه الاستراتيجيه وهذه
الطريقه في محاربته عن طريق طائرات ومن
الجو لن تؤتي اكلها كما يجب ان يكون تحدث
عن عدم وجود امد زمني تحدث عن مسرح عمليات
فرضه تنظيم الدوله وليس طرفا اخر تحدث
ايضا عن ما تناقلته وسائل الاعلام كثيره
اليوم من قتل للمدنيين لعدم نجاعه ربما
كما يرى كثيرون هذه الضربات الجويه عن بعد
يعني بمثل هذه المعايير كيف يمكن ان يحقق
الانتصار وقد اشرت الى هذه النقطه في
بدايه
البرنامج تحدث الضيف من من المملكه
العربيه السعوديه عن المسرحين هذا ما فرضه
داعش بالفعل وانا قلت في بدايه حديثي ان
ال الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او التحالف
يريد فصل هذين المسرحين اليوم عندما نتحدث
عن هذا التنظيم اليوم انه تنظيم فريد من
نوعه اولا انه تنظيم فاجا الكل احتل مساحه
ارض بسرعه وليونه ومفاجاه كبيره تساوي
مساحه الاردن مع عدد سكان الشعب تحت
سيطرته ما يقارب ايضا عدد سكان الاردن
اليوم غنم سلاحا مهما جدا يعطيه حركيه
عاليه ولكنه سلاح او تنظيم لديه كل مقومات
الدوله القويه يعني عنده السلطه السياسيه
عنده السلطه العسكريه عنده المال وعنده
الايديولوجيه والتي هي مهمه جدا السفيه
السلطه الفكريه نعم نتحدث اليوم عنه ولكن
اليوم هو جيش مختلف عن الجيوش الباقيه هو
قاتل كما تقاتل الجيوش الاساسيه ولكن
المشكله اليوم بعد هذه الضربات الجويه ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او التحالف
يريد ضرب هذه الحركيه لانه من يدرس خريطه
انتشار هذا التنظيم يدرس خريطه انتشاره
على الطرقات السريعه الممتده من شمال
بغداد وصولا الى الرقه وهذا امر يعطيه هذه
الحيويه هذه الضربات تمنعه من الحركيه
لتخلق مشكله اكبر للتحالف وهي ان يذهب هذا
التنظيم لانه لين او فلكسبل كما يقال
ليذهب الى الحرب المدنيه ومن يستطيع
اخراجه من الرقه دون قوات على الارض اذا
هي حرب شوارع ربما يصعب التصدي لها جنرال
مارك كيمت بطائرات جويه يعني تحدثت عن
تدريب القوات قوات المعارضه السوريه هناك
من تحدث ايضا عن الجيش العراقي الذي ربما
سيكون جزءا وهو يعاني ما يعانيه بدليل ما
حدث في القلويه يعني يوم امس فق قط وما
تكبده من خسائر هناك من يتحدث عن قوات
البش مر وبالمناسبه قوات البش مر قادتها
ايضا يعني تحدثوا بصوت عال بانهم يرفضون
القتال خارج مناطقهم على من التعويل
اذا عفوا هذا السؤال نعم هذا هذا السؤال
موجه لك جنرال
ماركت يس نعم نعم اننا نشعر بثقه كبيره
بان قوات الامن العراقيه الان وقد حظيت
بالدعم الذي تحتاجه ستبدا بالهجوم فلو
اخذنا الاسس اللوجستيه والملاذ الامن الي
تمتعت به داعش خلال الاشهر الماضيه داخل
سوريا ولو ضغطنا عليها في ذلك فان ذلك
سيحرم من قدراتها الهجوميه قدراتها
الهجوميه داخل العراق وبالتالي في القوات
العراقيه وقوات بشك الي عودت ترتيبها
وتكوينها ستستطيع ان تكون بقوه كافيه خلال
فتره بسيطه بدعم امريكي لاستعاده الكثير
من الاراضي التي فقدتها منذ شهر حزيران
مايو الماضي الى حد الان جنرال كمت لازلنا
نتحدث عن ربما ما يمكن تحقيقه
عسكريا الجنرال المتقاعد الياس حنا اشار
الى عده
سلطات يملكها هذا التنظيم نهيك عن السلطه
الفكريه او الايديولوجيا التي يملكها كيف
لهذه
الاستراتيجيه ان تنجح ايضا في التغلب على
هذه
النقطه ما قلناه قبل قليل هو انه لا يمكن
الاستراتيجيه عسكريه فقط لذلك فان
استراتيجيه الرئيس تتضمن عده اتجاهات
مختلفه فهناك الجانب العسكري فيها وفيها
ايضا جانب دبلوماسي ليس هناك اي امكانيه
ان نحارب هذه الحرب حاليا لو كانت
الولايات المتحده لوحدها لكن الامر لو جرى
عن طريق دبلوماسي فهو الذي جعل معظم دول
العالم تساهم في هذه المعركه وهذا يعتبر
عنصر دبلوماسي مهم جدا في الاستراتيجيه
وان الوزارات التمويل والميزانيه سوف تمنع
توفي ك الاموال لهؤلاء الجهاديين لاننا
نريد ان نحرم داعش من مصادر اموالها وكما
قلت الايديولوجيه ايضا لابد هناك هجوم
مضاد
فكري
يدرك ويمكن ان يوضح بشكل لا لبس فيه بان
الا ايديولوجيه
تدعيها
داعش غير صحيحه فهي لا تعكس سياسه صحيحه
ولا تعكس دينا صحيحا ولا ثقافه صحيحه او
جيده فهذه ليست دوله اسلاميه في الحقيقه
بل هي دوله لا اسلاميه و وكما هي حال كل
الاستراتيجيات لابد ان تكونها استراتيجيه
تضم كل هذه العناصر الدبلوماسيه والعسكريه
والماليه والمعلوماتيه لتعمل سويه لتحقيق
هدف مشترك وانا على ثقه بانه لو اتسم
بالصبر والمثابره لتطبيق مع ضد داعش ما
نفس ما اضعناه ضد القاعده في العراق و
فاننا قد لا نستطيع ان ندمر داعش تماما
خلال فتره قصيره الا ان يمكن ان نخفف الى
حد كبير خطرها على الدول الاخرى في
المنطقه وضح تماما دع نتحول الى جده مره
اخرى دكتور علي دكتور علي باعتقادك ما
المعايير التي يمكن فعلا ان تعتمد لتحديد
اي انتصار للولايات المتحده ومن ورائها كل
الدول في هذا الحلف ضد تنظيم الدوله
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده معاييرها
اعلنتها وهي واضحه وهي مطارده ال حتى في
خطاب الرئيس اوباما مطارده التنظيم
واجباره على الاختباء كمرحله اولى ثم
القضاء عليه في مخابره فهذه الاستراتيجيه
الامريكيه وهي منها نستطيع ان نشتق معايير
الانتصار اذا استطاعوا ان يجبرهم على
الاختباء اذا استطاعوا ان يدمروا بنيتهم
التي لا اراها انا لا ارى لهم بنيه واضحه
يمكن تدميرها اذا امكن ايضا قتل اكبر عدد
من منهم تكون الولايات المتحده قد حققت
اهدافها ولكن لتحقيق هذه الاهداف التي
تخدم جميع الاطراف يمكن طالما ان العراق
ترفض وجود قوات او تدخل قوات يمكن ان
نعتمد على القوات المنقوله جوا القوات
الخاصه القوات الصاعقه التي تضرب وتتحرك
ايضا على الانشقاقات الكبيره في الجيش
السوري تجميع من كانوا فعلا في الجيش
السوري وشقو وتشجيع من هم الان تحت السلاح
على الانشقاق وتجميعهم في شمال العراق
بحيث انه اذا قامت هذه القوات
الخاصه بتطهير منطقه و وتامينها يتحركون
هؤلاء
ويتشبثون بالارض لابد من ايجاد تكتيك
لتسريع العمليات
ول التشبث بالارض دا عن ذلك ستتحول الى
حرب تدمير
ومطارده من الجو لا طائله من ورائها اشكرك
جزيل الشكر الدكتور علي بن حسن التواتي
الكاتب والمحلل الاستراتيجي كنت معنا من
جده كما نشكر جزيل الشكر ضيفنا من واشنطن
الجنرال ماركت مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي
السابق ونشكر جزيل الشكر ضيفنا من بيروت
العميد المتقاعد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي ذا مشاهدينا تنتهي هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي
باذن الله في قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر
جديد السلام
عليكم
[موسيقى]
ا